Back in the winter of 2022, in the days and weeks before Russia invaded Ukraine, there was one thing that most Ukrainians and most Russians had in common. They both insisted that war was impossible. War was unbelievable. And one reason it was unbelievable is that many families, possibly most families on either side of the border, have family members in the other country.
早在2022年冬天，即俄罗斯入侵乌克兰前的数日和数周里，大多数乌克兰人和大多数俄罗斯人都有一个共同点。他们都坚称战争是不可能的。战争是不可思议的。而之所以觉得不可思议，是因为许多家庭，可能边境两侧的大多数家庭，在对方国家都有亲人。
Many Russians have some Ukrainian roots. Many Ukrainians have spent time living in Russia. Even President Zelenskyy, like many Ukrainians, grew up speaking Russian. He had a career in Russia, starred in Russian movies, performed comedy for Russian audiences. Even Putin's seen him perform-- called him a good actor years ago.
许多俄罗斯人都有乌克兰血统。许多乌克兰人曾在俄罗斯生活过。甚至泽连斯基总统也像许多乌克兰人一样，是在讲俄语的环境中长大的。他在俄罗斯有过职业生涯，主演过俄罗斯电影，为俄罗斯观众表演过喜剧。甚至普京也看过他的表演——几年前还称赞他是个好演员。
So when Russians did start the war, it wasn't just on the battlefield or in the airspace over Ukrainian cities. It was within families. This is something I had no idea about, the way a conflict like this might take the normal disagreements between people and blow them up. When you think about it, like, of course, right?
所以当俄罗斯人真的发动战争时，它不仅发生在战场上或乌克兰城市上空。它还发生在家庭内部。这是我之前完全没想到的，这种冲突会把人与人之间正常的意见分歧放大。当你仔细想想，这当然会发生，对吧？
It was the writer Masha Gessen who explained this to me. Masha was born in Moscow, moved to the United States as a teenager with their family, then moved back to Russia as an adult to work as a journalist. They've written several books, now currently a staff writer at The New Yorker. And what Masha has put together today is a very unusual story where they try to capture what this is like by looking at one family and the fights they get into related to the war. So what you're about to hear is one family and eight fights. Here's Masha.
是作家玛莎·格森向我解释了这一点。玛莎出生于莫斯科，十几岁时随家人移居美国，成年后又回到俄罗斯担任记者。他们写过几本书，目前是《纽约客》的特约撰稿人。玛莎今天带来了一个非常不寻常的故事，他们试图通过观察一个家庭以及他们围绕战争发生的争吵来捕捉这种感受。所以你们接下来要听到的是一个家庭和八场争吵。有请玛莎。
In normal times, we keep the peace in families by letting things go, by accommodating, by forgetting things or pretending not to notice things. But when war starts, even the quietest, most conflict-avoidant people start fighting. Just before the war began, on February 21, 2022, two people sat at a long dining table in a Moscow apartment.
在正常时期，我们通过让步、迁就、遗忘或假装没看见来维持家庭和睦。但当战争爆发时，即使是最安静、最回避冲突的人也会开始争吵。战争开始前夕，2022年2月21日，两个人坐在莫斯科公寓的长餐桌旁。
These are my friends Nadia and Karen. They are at the center of this constellation of people I'm going to tell you about. I've known Nadia the longest-- since she was a college student in Moscow about 25 years ago. She was tall, blonde, butch, very cool. She still is. Soon after graduating, in 2003, she moved to Kyiv.
他们是我的朋友娜迪亚和卡伦。他们是我今天要讲述的这一群人的核心。我认识娜迪亚最久——大约25年前，她还在莫斯科读大学时我们就认识了。她个子高高的，金发，中性打扮，非常酷。现在依然如此。2003年毕业后不久，她搬到了基辅。
And there's Karen a gay man, a friend I've known through many relationships. Twelve years ago, Karen and Nadia had a baby together. They lived in different countries, but it didn't seem like a big deal. Karen was in Moscow, Nadia in Ukraine, in Kyiv, so their son Luka was growing up in Kyiv but regularly visited his dad in Moscow. And on this night, all three of them were in Karen's apartment in Moscow. Luka had gone to bed. The adults were watching a speech by Vladimir Putin.
还有卡伦，一个男同性恋者，一个我通过许多关系认识的朋友。十二年前，卡伦和娜迪亚生了一个孩子。他们住在不同的国家，但这似乎没什么大不了的。卡伦在莫斯科，娜迪亚在乌克兰的基辅，所以他们的儿子卢卡在基辅长大，但经常去莫斯科看望父亲。就在那天晚上，他们三人都待在卡伦莫斯科的公寓里。卢卡已经睡了。大人们正在看弗拉基米尔·普京的演讲。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语交谈]
Putin was declaring war. So Karen and Nadia had a fight.
普京宣布了战争。于是卡伦和娜迪亚吵了起来。
Fight number one-- where does Luka go? Even before Putin's speech, Nadia was ready. She didn't think the war would happen, but she'd made a plan for Luka if war broke out-- a plan she hadn't told Karen about until now.
第一场争吵——卢卡去哪儿？甚至在普京演讲之前，娜迪亚就已经准备好了。她不认为战争会发生，但如果战争爆发，她已经为卢卡做好了计划——一个她直到现在才告诉卡伦的计划。
By that time, I already knew that we're not going back to Ukraine. We already had tickets to Berlin.
到那时，我已经知道我们不会回乌克兰了。我们已经买好了去柏林的机票。
And who said what? What was the argument?
谁说了什么？争论的内容是什么？
Well, before he was saying nothing is going to happen, and you're exaggerating, and things like this. But then, he was like, OK, maybe something's is going to happen in Ukraine. But you definitely shouldn't, you know, take the kid away to some other country.
嗯，之前他说什么都不会发生，说我在夸大其词之类的。但后来他说，好吧，乌克兰可能会发生点什么。但你绝对不应该，你知道，把孩子带到其他国家去。
I was like, if there's going to be a war, it is safer to stay in Moscow--
我说，如果真的有战争，待在莫斯科会更安全——
This is Karen.
这是卡伦。
--because nobody's going to attack Moscow. I live 10 minutes' walk from Kremlin. [CHUCKLES] I can't imagine the war can come into town.
——因为没人会攻击莫斯科。我住的地方离克里姆林宫只有10分钟步行路程。[轻笑] 我无法想象战争会蔓延到城里来。
He was saying, "no, I want him to stay in Moscow. It's the safest place in the world. I don't want him to go to Berlin." And we actually-- we didn't succeed too much in persuading him.
他说：“不，我希望他待在莫斯科。这是世界上最安全的地方。我不希望他去柏林。”而且我们实际上……我们没能太成功地说服他。
And she didn't push too hard because that wasn't her way.
她没有太坚持，因为那不是她的风格。
I don't know. I just hate fighting. I just hate when it gets ugly. Whenever I even sense that this might be the situation, I would just go in the opposite direction. It would never actually get to far as to have a fight with someone.
我不知道。我只是讨厌争吵。我讨厌事情变得难看。每当我感觉到可能会出现这种情况时，我就会朝着相反的方向走。它从来不会真正发展到与人争吵的地步。
And I think I'm so used to this. It has been for years like this. So we just said, "we're going to go there for two weeks."
我想我已经习惯这样了。多年来一直如此。所以我们只是说，“我们去那儿待两周。”
We, as in Nadia, Luka, and Nadia's girlfriend, Sophie.
“我们”是指娜迪亚、卢卡和娜迪亚的女友苏菲。
And only on two weeks he agreed. And everybody was like, yeah, two weeks. Of course. Right. But then I called Sophie anyway, and I said, "Take everything, including the summer clothes."
他只同意两周。大家都说，嗯，两周。当然。对。但我还是给苏菲打了电话，我说：“带上所有东西，包括夏装。”
Including the summer clothes.
包括夏装。
Now, Sophie flies to Berlin with as much stuff as she can carry on a plane. Nadia and Luka meet her there.
现在，苏菲带着她能在飞机上携带的所有东西飞往柏林。娜迪亚和卢卡在那里与她会合。
Am I understanding this correctly that you're, like, talking him into two weeks because you're not going to have a big fight with him?
我理解得对吗，你是为了避免跟他大吵一架，才劝他同意两周的？
Yeah, but it's just the story of our relationship. We're just avoiding the conflicts all the time.
对，但这只是我们关系的故事。我们一直在回避冲突。
Well, she is. This is how she is with everyone.
嗯，她是这样。她对待每个人都是这样。
So Nadia and Luka leave. Karen stays. And Russia invades Ukraine. Karen is going to protests, but he's lost, crying every day. After a few days, he goes to a goodbye party at a friend's apartment.
于是娜迪亚和卢卡离开了。卡伦留下了。俄罗斯入侵了乌克兰。卡伦去参加抗议，但他迷茫了，每天都在哭。几天后，他去朋友家参加了一个告别派对。
And there, there were a lot of our common friends-- I don't know, 15 people. And everybody were discussing tickets, when and where everybody's going.
那里有很多我们共同的朋友——不知道，大概15个人吧。大家都在讨论机票，每个人什么时候走，去哪里。
I can tell you when this was, because I was there. March 4. And it's true that this was all our friends were talking about. There were rumors that Russia would close the border, impose martial law, conscript all the men, and just a general sense that you had to get out now or it will be too late. At the party, Karen started to get upset. Like, wait, you were all just going to leave me here?
我可以告诉你这是什么时候，因为我也在场。3月4日。大家讨论的确实全都是这些。有传言说俄罗斯会关闭边境、实施戒严、征召所有男性，总之大家普遍觉得必须马上走，否则就太晚了。在派对上，卡伦开始难过起来。比如，等一下，你们都要把我留在这里吗？
And that was the moment I realized that if everybody is leaving, then I'm going to do it as well.
那一刻我意识到，如果大家都走了，那我也得走。
So Karen and his boyfriend buy tickets. To give you a sense of just how difficult it was to get out by then, they end up flying to Ulan-Bator, the capital of Mongolia. From there, after a few days, they fly to Seoul, South Korea, then to Dubai, then to Yerevan, the capital of Armenia, where they stay for a bit.
于是卡伦和他的男友买了机票。为了让你了解当时离开有多困难，他们最后飞到了蒙古首都乌兰巴托。从那里出发，几天后，他们飞往韩国首尔，然后是迪拜，最后是亚美尼亚首都埃里温，在那里待了一阵子。
Fight number two-- who is Russian, and who is Ukrainian? To understand the roots of this next fight, we have to go back a long time, to New Year's Eve 2010, when Karen and Nadia met.
第二场争吵——谁是俄罗斯人，谁是乌克兰人？要理解接下来这场争吵的根源，我们得追溯到很久以前，2010年的除夕夜，当时卡伦和娜迪亚相遇。
My friend Vera, she introduced me to Nadia, saying like, "This is Karen, and he wants to have a child. And this is Nadia, and she wants it too. So please invite me when everything is done and you're going to baptize your kid, and I'll be his or her godmother." And that was it. And we were like, OK, let's talk. And several times, we talked about it. And we decided, yes, let's do it.
我的朋友维拉把我介绍给娜迪亚，说：“这是卡伦，他想要个孩子。这是娜迪亚，她也想要。所以一切搞定给孩子受洗的时候请邀请我，我要做教母。”就是这样。我们当时就说，好吧，聊聊吧。我们谈了几次。然后我们决定，是的，就这么办。
They were 31 and 28. They were both queer. They were both Buddhists. So they had that in common. Other than that, they didn't discuss any of the big issues of how to raise a child-- what school he would go to, what languages he would speak, how they would explain the world to him.
他们当时分别是31岁和28岁。他们都是酷儿。他们都信奉佛教。所以他们有共同点。除此以外，他们没有讨论过抚养孩子的任何重大问题——他该上什么学校，该说哪种语言，该如何向他解释这个世界。
Nadia knew she wanted to raise him in Ukraine. She'd moved there from Moscow years before this. Karen wanted to stay in Moscow, but he'd visit. They weren't exactly friends. They went straight to being co-parents. They figured they'd work it out.
娜迪亚知道她想在乌克兰养育他。在此前几年她就从莫斯科搬到那里了。卡伦想留在莫斯科，但他会去探望。他们算不上朋友。他们直接成为了共同抚养人。他们想他们会解决这些问题的。
A few years later, it was time to choose a school for Luka. Nadia had to make a commitment to the next 10 years or so of her son's schooling and the language in which he was going to study. At the time, Kyiv had schools with instruction in Ukrainian, Russian, English, German, French. Nadia was struggling to make a choice, but Karen had a definite opinion.
几年后，到了为卢卡选择学校的时候。娜迪亚必须为儿子未来十年的学业以及他学习的语言做出承诺。当时，基辅有以乌克兰语、俄语、英语、德语、法语教学的学校。娜迪亚在做选择时很纠结，但卡伦有明确的意见。
Of course, I was hoping that he will study Russian and he will read and write in Russian. I mean, all his family, including his Ukrainian part of the family, speaks only Russian. And he is thinking in Russian. He never reads in Ukrainian. So what's the point to try to artificially implement the language that he doesn't use and will not use when he grows up?
当然，我当时希望他能学习俄语，读写俄语。我的意思是，他所有的家人，包括乌克兰那边的家人，都只说俄语。而且他的思维也是用俄语。他从不读乌克兰语。所以，为什么要强行推行他不用、长大后也不会用的语言呢？
Karen's kind of a funny one to be championing Russian culture. He grew up an outsider. His heritage is Armenian, Jewish, Greek, and, yeah, some Russian. He has dark, curly hair, a trimmed beard, a wide, chiseled face, and a long, prominent nose. He's beautiful.
卡伦作为俄罗斯文化的拥护者有点滑稽。他从小就是个局外人。他的血统是亚美尼亚、犹太、希腊，当然，还有一点俄罗斯血统。他有深色的卷发，修剪整齐的胡须，宽阔的轮廓分明的脸庞，还有一个突出的高鼻梁。他很帅。
He also doesn't look Russian at all. It's not easy to grow up in Russia when you don't look ethnically Russian. I know. I grew up in Russia looking un-Russian, and I got teased, chased, and beaten up a lot. Karen's name marks him as an Armenian. He had to fight for the right to be Russian.
他看起来一点也不像俄罗斯人。当你的外貌不像俄罗斯民族时，在俄罗斯长大并不容易。我知道。我在俄罗斯长大，看起来就不像俄罗斯人，我经常被取笑、追赶和殴打。卡伦的名字标明了他的亚美尼亚血统。他不得不为自己作为俄罗斯人的权利而战。
Nadia, on the other hand, with her blonde hair and blue-gray eyes-- growing up in Moscow, she certainly never had to defend her right to be there. She moved to Kyiv as a kind of experiment and found that she loved it there. It became her home. Karen and a lot of Nadia's friends, though, kept assuming she was in Ukraine temporarily. On this particular night, Karen was a little drunk.
另一方面，娜迪亚有着金发和蓝灰色的眼睛——在莫斯科长大时，她当然从未需要捍卫自己在那里的权利。她搬到基辅作为一种尝试，发现自己很喜欢那里。那里成了她的家。然而，卡伦和娜迪亚的许多朋友一直认为她只是暂时待在乌克兰。就在那天晚上，卡伦有点喝多了。
And that's when we started this fight. It started over schools, and then it went to that Ukrainian culture is not a culture, and the language is not language, and all that. And he went on and on. And at first I was shocked. And so, he was like-- he said many things.
于是我们就开始了这场争吵。起初是因为学校，然后上升到乌克兰文化不是文化，语言也不是语言，诸如此类。他没完没了地说。起初我震惊了。他说了很多话。
And then, I was like, What am I supposed to do? Because I can't fight with him. I don't-- because I have to keep good relationships because he is Luka's father. So I was like, OK, please, don't say these things. Because we Ukrainians-- and he was like, no, you're not Ukrainians.
然后，我说，我该怎么办？因为我不能跟他吵。因为我必须保持良好的关系，因为他是卢卡的父亲。所以我说，好吧，求你了，别说这些了。因为我们乌克兰人——他说，不，你们不是乌克兰人。
You're Russians. You're from Moscow, and he's Russian. And I was like, OK.
你们是俄罗斯人。你们来自莫斯科，他也是俄罗斯人。我说，好吧。
Yeah, of course, I was biased, and I am still biased.
是的，当然，我有偏见，而且我现在依然有偏见。
But biased how?
但什么样的偏见？
Biased toward Russian heritage. This is important part of my identity. And I was convinced that this is an important part of his identity also.
对俄罗斯血统的偏见。这是我身份认同的重要部分。我也深信这是他身份认同的重要部分。
In fact, Karen had always hoped that Nadia would move back to Moscow. Nadia had zero intention of doing that.
事实上，卡伦一直希望娜迪亚能搬回莫斯科。娜迪亚完全没有这样的打算。
The thing is, I always hated the idea that he has to go to Moscow even over the vacation. And I never liked the influence it was on him.
问题是，我一直讨厌他甚至在假期也必须去莫斯科的想法。而且我从来不喜欢这对他的影响。
Not that she said this to Karen. Why start a fight?
并不是她把这些话告诉了卡伦。为什么要引发争吵呢？
Because all the time Luka was going to Russia for one month a year, his father was insistently feeding him-- like, "You're Russian. You're not Ukrainian. You got nothing to do with Ukraine. There's no such thing as Ukrainian culture. The Ukrainian language is not good, and there's this tremendous Russian culture-- you should heading towards that."
因为卢卡每年去俄罗斯待一个月期间，他父亲总是坚持向他灌输——比如，“你是俄罗斯人。你不是乌克兰人。你跟乌克兰没关系。根本没有乌克兰文化这回事。乌克兰语不好，而且有这么伟大的俄罗斯文化——你应该向往那个。”
And then Luka would be coming back and saying, you know, "I don't like to attend some Ukrainian holidays or wear vyshyvanka." And I was like, "Why would you do that?"
然后卢卡回来后会说，你知道，“我不喜欢参加乌克兰节日或者穿乌克兰刺绣衫。”我说，“你为什么要那样做？”
A vyshyvanka is a traditional Ukrainian embroidered Shirt. Karen told me he didn't have anything against Ukrainian tradition in particular.
乌克兰刺绣衫（vyshyvanka）是一种传统的乌克兰刺绣衬衫。卡伦告诉我，他并不是专门反对乌克兰传统。
We all know that traditional costumes are just literally bad taste for everybody. No matter if this is vyshyvanka or traditional Russian costume, we look down to that in general because it's silly, because it has something to do with the nationalism we all hated-- always. Like, at least we thought we hated.
我们都知道，传统服饰对所有人来说简直就是品味低俗。不管是乌克兰刺绣衫还是传统的俄罗斯服饰，我们总的来说都看不起，因为这很傻，因为它与我们一直痛恨的民族主义有关——至少我们以为我们痛恨。
There's a big difference between Russian and Ukrainian national costumes. The vyshyvanka, long before the war, was a symbol of the renaissance of Ukrainian culture and identity after the fall of the Soviet Union. Ukraine was a former colony of Russia. Karen, like most Russians, was oblivious to this.
俄罗斯民族服装和乌克兰民族服装有很大区别。乌克兰刺绣衫在战争爆发前很久，就已经是苏联解体后乌克兰文化和身份复兴的象征。乌克兰是俄罗斯的前殖民地。卡伦像大多数俄罗斯人一样，对此一无所知。
This is not about Russia or Ukraine. This is about, like, sense of style.
这跟俄罗斯或乌克兰无关。这关乎，比如说，审美感。
Kind of. To Nadia, it was about Karen's attitudes toward all things Ukrainian. He thought Kyiv was a backwater.
算是吧。在娜迪亚看来，这关乎卡伦对所有乌克兰事物的态度。他认为基辅是一个落后的地方。
I hate to mention it, but he was visiting museums or theaters or concerts only when I was coming to Kyiv, and I took him to the same two or three museums. And not to mention theaters-- there are almost none in Kyiv.
我讨厌提及这一点，但他只有在我来基辅时才会参观博物馆、剧院或音乐会，而我带他去的都是同样的二三家博物馆。更不用说剧院了——基辅几乎没有剧院。
How much theater and museums did you get when you were a kid?
你小时候参观过多少剧院和博物馆？
Unfortunately not too much. Not too many. Because I was born and raised in Siberia in Irkutsk. And this is not, like, a big cultural center.
遗憾的是不多。没多少。因为我是在西伯利亚的伊尔库茨克出生长大的。那里可不是什么大文化中心。
Every parent wants to give their children what they didn't have growing up. Nadia, unlike Karen, grew up in the center of Moscow, in the very heart of the empire, in a privileged family. Karen couldn't believe she was willing to give up what he had so longed for as a kid. Nadia, for her part, wanted to avoid conflict. So in the end, Luka didn't go to a Ukrainian school or a Russian school. He enrolled in a German school in Kyiv.
每个父母都想给孩子他们小时候没有的东西。娜迪亚和卡伦不同，她在莫斯科中心长大，就在帝国的核心，生活在优越的家庭中。卡伦无法相信她竟然愿意放弃他小时候梦寐以求的东西。娜迪亚为了避免冲突，最后，卢卡既没上乌克兰学校，也没上俄罗斯学校。他在基辅报读了一所德国学校。
When the war started, all those things that Luka had heard his father say, that he and his mother are really Russian, these ideas hit Luka hard. His father's country was bombing his motherland.
战争开始时，卢卡从父亲那里听到的所有话，即他和母亲其实是俄罗斯人，这些想法重重地打击了卢卡。他父亲的国家正在轰炸他的母亲国。
Luka was crying and saying, "It's my fault. I'm Russian." So I called his father, and I said, "Look what have you done. Luka now thinks that it's his fault because he is Russian."
卢卡哭着说：“这是我的错。我是俄罗斯人。”所以我给他的父亲打了电话，我说，“看看你都做了些什么。卢卡现在认为这是他的错，因为他是俄罗斯人。”
He felt that he's half this and have that, and now there is huge inner conflict inside of him. Because to him, to his kid's mind, that was like one half of him is attacking the other half of himself.
他觉得自己一半是这个一半是那个，现在他内心产生了巨大的冲突。因为对他，对他孩子的心智来说，这就像他的一半在攻击他自己的另一半。
Talking to Luka didn't help much. Maybe he could be convinced that the war wasn't his fault, but he was still stuck with this problem of being both Ukrainian and Russian. The war was tearing him apart. It maybe didn't help that he and his moms were still on the move. They finally landed in Lisbon.
跟卢卡谈话没多大用处。也许可以让他相信战争不是他的错，但他仍然面临着既是乌克兰人又是俄罗斯人的问题。战争让他深受撕裂之苦。或许他和妈妈们一直在搬家也没什么帮助。他们最终定居在里斯本。
I was thinking maybe, suggesting maybe, you think you're going to be Portuguese since we live in Portugal? And he was like, "No, no, no, I'm German. I'm definitely German." And I was like, "Why?" And then the psychologist explained to me that at this age they just pick the safest environment.
我当时在想，也许，提议一下，既然我们住在葡萄牙，你觉得你会成为葡萄牙人吗？他说，“不，不，不，我是德国人。我绝对是德国人。”我说，“为什么？”然后心理医生向我解释说，在这个年龄，他们只会选择最安全的环境。
Luka had gone to German school in Kyiv. He was going to start attending a German school in Lisbon. Choosing Germany was a way to avoid choosing Ukraine or choosing Russia, a way to avoid choosing between his parents. I think Germany felt neutral.
卢卡在基辅上过德国学校。他要在里斯本开始上一所德国学校。选择德国是一种避免选择乌克兰或选择俄罗斯的方式，是避免在他父母之间做选择的方式。我觉得德国感觉很中立。
Fights number three and number four-- Crimea and the globe. A few years back, Karen surprised Nadia. For his part of summer vacation, he suggested taking Luka to Crimea. Crimea had been under Russian occupation for several years. Once upon a time, it had been a vacation destination for both Russians and Ukrainians. But after the occupation, Crimea was off limits for Ukrainians.
第三和第四场争吵——克里米亚和地球仪。几年前，卡伦给了娜迪亚一个惊喜。在暑假期间，他建议带卢卡去克里米亚。克里米亚已经被俄罗斯占领了好几年。曾几何时，它是俄罗斯人和乌克兰人的度假胜地。但在占领之后，克里米亚对乌克兰人来说成了禁区。
And I was like, "No, no, no, we don't go to Crimea." And they were like, "No, come on." Because the whole family of his father used to spend summer in Crimea, so they will continue doing that. And they were calling us and saying, "Can Luka come so the kids can spend time together." And I was like, "Yeah, I don't mind." But we don't go to Crimea, we Ukrainians, because it's not our land and there's the whole thing about it.
我说，“不，不，不，我们不去克里米亚。”他们说，“不，得了吧。”因为他父亲的整个家庭过去常在克里米亚度过夏天，所以他们会继续那样做。他们打电话给我们说，“卢卡可以去吗，这样孩子们可以待在一起。”我说，“是的，我不介意。”但我们不去克里米亚，我们乌克兰人，因为它不是我们的土地，而且关于它有一堆事情。
Imagine you live in a house and one day someone comes in with a gun and just takes over the second floor. And it wasn't a bunch of empty rooms. Your cousin was living there. Now your cousin isn't allowed to talk to you. And suddenly, your friend goes, "Hey, let's go visit the guy who's living on the second floor of your house. I've always liked the view from there."
想象一下你住在一所房子里，有一天有人拿着枪进来，直接占领了二楼。那可不是几间空房间。你的表亲住在那里。现在你的表亲不被允许跟你说话。突然，你的朋友说，“嘿，我们去看看那个住在你家二楼的人吧。我一直很喜欢从那里看风景。”
I never shared this point of view that you cannot visit annexed territories. Well, I guess for Ukrainians, it's completely different. For them, if you go there, it means that you support the idea that Crimea is part of Russia or that that was legal.
我从未赞同不能访问被吞并领土的观点。好吧，我想对于乌克兰人来说，这完全不同。对他们来说，如果你去了那里，意味着你支持克里米亚是俄罗斯一部分的观点，或者认为那是合法的。
He really couldn't see what the big deal was. They'd go there, support the local economy. After all, the people of Crimea weren't to blame for being occupied.
他真的看不出这有什么大不了的。他们去那儿，支持当地经济。毕竟，克里米亚人并不是因为被占领而受到指责。
There's no way I can explain what I feel. So the only way I could say, "OK, it doesn't matter what I feel. Probably, you're right." But on the 1st of September, the kid would have to go to Ukrainian school. And then when they ask him how he spent the summer, and if he says he goes to Crimea, he's going to be in big trouble.
我无法解释我的感受。所以我唯一能说的就是，“好吧，我的感受不重要。可能你是对的。”但到了9月1日，孩子就得去乌克兰学校了。当他们问他暑假是怎么过的，如果他说他去了克里米亚，他会有大麻烦。
That worked. The Crimean vacation was averted. But then came the globe. When Russia occupied Crimea, it printed up new maps and made new globes that labeled Crimea as part of Russia. And as Nadia recalls, Karen and his boyfriend were coming for a visit and bringing a globe as a present for Luka. And on the plane, they realized that this is a Russian globe. It showed Crimea as a part of Russia. This would be a problem when they'd land in Ukraine and have to go through customs.
这招奏效了。克里米亚度假被阻止了。但后来出现了地球仪。当俄罗斯占领克里米亚时，它印刷了新的地图，制作了新的地球仪，将克里米亚标记为俄罗斯的一部分。正如娜迪亚所回忆的那样，卡伦和他的男友来访，带来一个地球仪作为送给卢卡的礼物。在飞机上，他们意识到这是一个俄罗斯的地球仪。它显示克里米亚是俄罗斯的一部分。当他们降落在乌克兰必须过海关时，这会是个问题。
And they got really scared that somebody would decide to check it, and they'll be in big trouble. They'll be stopped and not allowed to enter the Ukraine because they brought the globe with Crimea being marked as part of Russia. So they were really scared, but it's-- but they couldn't throw it away because it was a big thing to get rid of.
他们非常害怕有人会决定检查它，那样他们会有大麻烦。他们会被拦截，不被允许进入乌克兰，因为他们带来了一个把克里米亚标记为俄罗斯一部分的地球仪。所以他们真的很害怕，但是——但是他们不能扔掉它，因为处理掉它是个大工程。
It's really obvious. And, you know, in a toilet-- it's not even many places where you can leave it. So they kind of had this poker face, and they crossed the customs, and nobody even checked.
它真的很显眼。而且，你知道，在厕所里——甚至没多少地方可以放下它。所以他们有点死撑着，过了海关，居然没人检查。
They left the airport. They took a taxi to Nadia's house. They gave the globe to Luka, and they told the story of how they had this realization on the plane and were stuck with the globe.
他们离开机场。坐出租车去了娜迪亚家。他们把地球仪给了卢卡，还讲述了他们在飞机上意识到这一点并被这个地球仪困住的故事。
And it was like the biggest joke. They would keep telling it to everyone. It was like, "Ha, ha, how funny. Imagine how stupid." And I was stuck with this thing in my house.
这就像最大的笑话。他们一直在告诉每个人。就像是，“哈哈，多好笑。想象一下多蠢。”而我却被这东西困在了家里。
The globe was Luka's, but it was Nadia who felt stuck with it.
地球仪是卢卡的，但娜迪亚觉得自己被它困住了。
I don't want to offend your father's feelings. It's really nice that-- and it's your present. And I know if I throw it away, it would be a huge scandal. So I was kind of saying "I'm really, really sorry, and I totally understand. But again, it might be some other people visiting, other Ukrainian people visiting my house and get offended. So I'm really sorry, but I'm getting rid of this globe." This is how-- it always been like this.
我不想伤害你父亲的感情。你送礼物挺好的——而且这是你的礼物。我知道如果我把它扔了，会是个巨大的丑闻。所以我当时有点在说，“我真的很抱歉，我完全理解。但再说一次，可能会有其他人，其他乌克兰人来我家，然后感到被冒犯。所以真的很抱歉，但我得把这个地球仪处理掉。”一直以来都是这样。
I couldn't really say, "What a fucking stupid idea. Why the hell you brought this globe to my house, give it to your son?" It always have to be the long way after other people might get offended.
我没法说，“这到底是什么他妈的蠢主意。你为什么要把这个地球仪带到我家，送给你儿子？”这总是得绕个大弯，考虑其他人是否会受到冒犯。
You know how people remember important events in completely different ways? In Karen's version of the story, there was no globe on the airplane, no fretting about customs. But there was a globe-- until there wasn't.
你知道人们是如何以完全不同的方式记住重要事件的吗？在卡伦的故事版本中，飞机上没有地球仪，也没有对海关的担忧。但确实有个地球仪——直到它不在了。
It's not there when I visited him the next time in Kyiv. And I was like, "And where is your globe?" And he was like, "Well, you know, there is a tiny mistake on that globe, so Mama hided it from me." And I realized what kind of mistake, but I never-- I can't recall that there was any fight about it. Did she tell you that we had fight about the globe?
下次我在基辅探望他时它不在了。我说，“你的地球仪呢？”他说，“嗯，你知道，那个地球仪上有一个小错误，所以妈妈把它藏起来了。”我意识到是什么样的错误，但我从来——我不记得关于它有任何争吵。她有没有告诉你我们为地球仪吵过架？
No, no. She said that she felt compelled to tell you that she had to get it out of the house because Ukrainian friends would see it.
没有，没有。她说她觉得不得不告诉你她必须把它弄出房子，因为乌克兰朋友会看到它。
Ah, no. So nobody saw it. There was no problem.
啊，不。所以没人看到它。没有问题。
[LAUGHS] Right. And did Luka actually say "tiny mistake?"
[笑] 对。卢卡真的说了“小错误”吗？
Yes. That was-- [LAUGHS] it was so touching, you know, so sweet of him. He was shy and was like, well, you know, there was a tiny mistake on the globe. So-- [LAUGHS] I never told him, like, "What the hell?" I didn't make any drama of it.
是的。那真是——[笑] 真是太感人了，你知道，他太贴心了。他很害羞，说，嗯，你知道，地球仪上有个小错误。所以——[笑] 我没告诉他，“这到底是怎么回事？”我没把它当回事。
And you didn't ask Nadia about it either?
你也没问娜迪亚这件事？
Of course not. It was clear that that's a problem.
当然没有。很明显那是个问题。
Fight number five-- Bucha. When the full scale invasion began, it began with the unimaginable. Almost immediately, Russian tanks were right outside of Kyiv. Russian troops occupied the Western suburbs. Ukrainians, fighting to keep them out of the city, blew up the bridge that connected the Western suburbs to Kyiv.
第五场争吵——布查。当全面入侵开始时，它以不可想象的方式开始了。几乎立刻，俄罗斯坦克就到了基辅郊外。俄军占领了西部郊区。乌克兰人为了把他们挡在城市之外，炸毁了连接西部郊区和基辅的桥梁。
And that bridge? It's just a short walk from Nadia's house. Their town borders Bucha, a place that's become synonymous with Russian war crimes. Nadia, her girlfriend, Sophie, and Luka were watching the invasion from a distance. And they were sick with worry because that house was not empty. Nadia's father and Sophie's mother were there, along with two pugs and several cats.
那座桥？离娜迪亚家只有一小段路程。他们的小镇与布查接壤，那里已成为俄罗斯战争罪行的代名词。娜迪亚、她的女友苏菲和卢卡在远处看着这场入侵。他们担心得要命，因为那座房子不是空的。娜迪亚的父亲和苏菲的母亲在那里，还有两只巴哥犬和几只猫。
Were they safe? Were they alive? Nadia posted on Facebook-- "We haven't heard from our parents in four days. I don't know how they're doing for food and water. They had a bit in reserve. I think they're probably afraid to fire up the stove. Is there anyone in the area who could show them a safe way out?"
他们安全吗？他们还活着吗？娜迪亚在Facebook上发帖——“我们已经四天没收到父母的消息了。我不知道他们怎么解决食物和水的问题。他们储备了一点。我想他们可能不敢生火做饭。这附近有没有人能给他们指一条安全的撤离路线？”
Nadia's father and Sophie's mother were the last people remaining in their gated community. They hung blankets over the windows. They had no electricity. And yes, they were scared.
娜迪亚的父亲和苏菲的母亲是他们封闭式社区里最后留下的人。他们在窗户上挂了毯子。他们没有电。是的，他们很害怕。
And here's the thing their daughters could not imagine-- they were in love. They'd gotten together. They lived by candlelight. They made a fire in the fireplace and cooked shishkebab. When the shelling was heavy, they lay in bed holding each other and felt the house rock back and forth.
这里有一件事是她们的女儿无法想象的——他们恋爱了。他们聚在一起。他们靠烛光生活。他们在壁炉里生火，烤了肉串。当炮击猛烈时，他们躺在床上紧紧拥抱对方，感受着房子的震动。
Finally, Nadia got hold of some Ukrainian soldiers in the area who told her there was a way out and they'd help. The soldiers came to the house and told Nadia's father-- let's call him Alex-- he had half an hour to pack.
最后，娜迪亚联系上了该地区的乌克兰士兵，士兵告诉她有一条撤离路线，他们会提供帮助。士兵来到房子里，告诉娜迪亚的父亲——我们就叫他亚历克斯吧——他有半小时的时间打包。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语交谈]
Oh, that's funny.
哦，那太好笑了。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语交谈]
I packed what I thought was particularly important. I took a coffee maker, a supply of coffee that I thought would last for six months, half a suitcase of coffee. Then, for some reason, I decided I should bring wine. And so, I packed a suitcase of wine. And then I decided to take some things that I thought would dear to Nadia. For some reason, I took some of her Buddhist figurines.
我打包了我觉得特别重要的东西。我拿了一台咖啡机，一堆我想能用六个月的咖啡，半箱咖啡。然后，出于某种原因，我决定带上葡萄酒。于是，我打包了一箱葡萄酒。然后我决定带上一些我觉得娜迪亚会珍惜的东西。出于某种原因，我带走了一些她的佛像。
It was a Buddha statue from IKEA.
那是个宜家买的佛像。
Wait, a Buddhist statue from IKEA?
等等，一个宜家的佛像？
Yeah, 10 euro Buddha statue. Because it was standing in the kitchen, like in the middle of everything, and my father thought it was somehow valuable.
是的，10欧元的佛像。因为它放在厨房里，就在中间，我父亲觉得它有什么价值。
They also brought the two pugs. They left the cats behind with lots of food. They drove into Kyiv, where they were joined by another couple and another pug. By this time, the car was so tightly packed, with stuff on top of people and pugs on top of stuff, the doors could only be closed from the outside.
他们还带了两只巴哥犬。他们把猫留下了，留下了大量的食物。他们开车进入基辅，在那里与另一对夫妇和另一只巴哥犬会合。到这时，车里塞得满满当当，人上面堆着东西，东西上面压着狗，车门只能从外面关上。
And they started driving, and it was really difficult with all these checkpoints. Everybody was, like, traumatized obviously. And this Ophelia, the one pug, she started to have a heat or whatever. Yeah? So they started to mate all the way.
他们开始开车，在这些检查站之间通行真的很困难。每个人显然都受到了创伤。那只叫奥菲莉亚的巴哥犬，发情了还是怎么的。是的吧？所以他们一路都在交配。
They were like driving, not sleeping, with all these checkpoints. And those two dogs are fucking on everyone because they didn't have a space. So it was happening on everyone. And whenever they were trying to pull them apart, they were biting.
他们一直在开车，没睡觉，路过所有检查站。那两只狗在每个人身上操来操去，因为没地方了。所以这事发生在每个人身上。每当他们试图把它们拉开时，它们就咬人。
Alex dropped off Lena and the other couple and the male pug in Western Ukraine and continued on to Bratislava, the capital of Slovakia, where he picked up Nadia for the drive through the rest of Europe.
亚历克斯把莉娜和另一对夫妇以及那只雄性巴哥犬放在乌克兰西部，然后继续前往斯洛伐克首都布拉迪斯拉发，在那里接上娜迪亚，开始穿越欧洲剩余路程的驾驶。
So it was my father and two dogs in a really smelly and dirty car full of some weird stuff he grabbed from the house when he had half an hour.
所以就是我和两条狗，在一辆臭烘烘又肮脏的车里，装满了他在半小时内从房子里抢出来的奇怪东西。
Nadia disposed of some of the junk, including the giant IKEA Buddha, almost as soon as she got in the car. Then they kept driving.
娜迪亚在车上几乎一出发就把一些垃圾扔掉了，包括那个巨大的宜家佛像。然后他们继续行驶。
And so we were driving and driving. And at some point the news came about Bucha. We started getting the pictures.
我们开着车。在某个时刻，关于布查的新闻传来了。我们开始收到照片。
Ukrainian troops had just entered Bucha after a month of Russian occupation. And what they saw was bodies-- bodies lying across sidewalks, bodies in the middle of the street, bodies with their hands tied behind their backs, demolished and burnt out houses, the charred remains of tanks, and more bodies of ordinary residents of Bucha who had been executed. These were pictures of streets Nadia and her father knew intimately. There was a park in Bucha where Nadia used to take Luka.
乌克兰军队在俄罗斯占领一个月后刚刚进入布查。他们看到的是尸体——尸体横在人行道上，尸体在街道中间，尸体双手被反绑在背后，被摧毁和烧毁的房子，坦克焦黑的残骸，还有更多在布查被处决的普通居民的尸体。这些街道照片是娜迪亚和她父亲非常熟悉的。布查有一个公园，娜迪亚过去常带卢卡去那里。
So Nadia was in the passenger seat, looking at her phone and seeing photos of the bodies. Then she and her father switched. She took the wheel.
所以娜迪亚坐在副驾驶位，看着手机，看着尸体的照片。然后她和父亲换了位置。她坐到了驾驶座。
So I kind of mentioned this Bucha thing. And I said, "Do you know what happened in Bucha?" He was like, "No." So I told him, and he was really surprised. And he was like, "Oh, my god. Really?" And I was like-- I told them all I knew. And he was trying to figure it out in his head.
我提到了这件事。我说，“你知道布查发生了什么吗？”他说，“不知道。”于是我告诉了他，他非常惊讶。他说，“天哪。真的吗？”我告诉了他们我知道的一切。他试图在脑子里搞清楚。
And then, he was like, "No, I can't believe in this. This must be-- you have to check this information. It can't be true." And I was like, "No, no, no. I already checked it. It was everywhere this morning, and the sources are reliable." And he was like, "No. No, no. It can't be." And he started giving me this lecture on Ukrainian propaganda.
然后，他说，“不，我不相信。这一定是——你得核实信息。不可能是真的。”我说，“不，不，不。我已经核实过了。今天早上到处都是，来源是可靠的。”他说，“不。不，不。不可能。”他开始给我讲关于乌克兰宣传的课。
Alex is Russian. He moved to Ukraine with Nadia 20 years ago. They built a house together, and he loved it. Now he was saying, "who knows if what you're reading is true. Or if it's true, is it the only truth? And anyway, things are never so black and white."
亚历克斯是俄罗斯人。他20年前和娜迪亚一起搬到乌克兰。他们一起盖了一座房子，他很喜欢那里。现在他说，“谁知道你读的东西是真的吗。或者如果是真的，那是唯一的真相吗？无论如何，事情从不是非黑即白的。”
And I was like, "Wait, wait, wait wait. Let's not switch to-- let's not discuss Ukraine propaganda. I'm telling you about the situation which happened in Bucha, which I consider my hometown."
我说，“等等，等等，等等。别切换到——别讨论乌克兰宣传。我是在告诉你布查发生的情况，我把它视为我的家乡。”
By suggesting that maybe things aren't so clear, so black and white, so knowable, Alex was, in fact, doing what Russian propaganda does. Its main message is that no one really knows what happened. If you weren't there, you can't judge. Everyone has a vested interest in everything. No one is a reliable source. It provides people with a myriad of ways to avoid the truth and no way to know it. But, of course, Alex was there. He had just been there.
通过暗示事情可能没有那么清晰、那么非黑即白、那么可知，亚历克斯实际上做了俄罗斯宣传所做的事情。其核心信息是没人真正知道发生了什么。如果你不在现场，你就不能评判。每个人在每件事上都有既得利益。没人是可靠的信息源。它为人们提供了无数种逃避真相的方法，却没有任何了解真相的途径。但当然，亚历克斯就在那里。他刚刚就在那里。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN].
[俄语交谈]。
I know Bucha inside out, and I've seen what kind of destruction was there. It was horrible. I know of some absolutely awful things when soldiers would come to people's house, when they turn all over the houses looking for weapons, looking for "terrorists." And I even know of a friend of a friend who went to get a bread, and while he was getting bread he was shot and killed.
我太了解布查了，我亲眼见过那里的破坏。太可怕了。我知道一些绝对糟糕的事情，士兵会闯入人们的家中，搜查房屋，寻找武器，寻找“恐怖分子”。我甚至知道有个朋友的朋友去买面包，在买面包时被枪杀。
And I know all of this. I'm well aware of it. But the thing is, when people talk about mass burials, about people shot with their hands tied behind their back, you know, as a scientist, I believe in facts. But these events, you know, I just haven't seen this for myself.
我知道这一切。我对此非常清楚。但问题是，当人们谈论乱葬坑、双手被反绑被枪杀的人时，你知道，作为科学家，我相信事实。但这些事件，你知道，我只是没有亲眼见到。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN].
[俄语交谈]。
It's not that I can't believe in it. I just refuse to believe it. I refuse to believe that Russian soldier came and took civilians, that he tied their hands, took them all out, and then shot them all.
不是我不能相信。我只是拒绝相信。我拒绝相信俄罗斯士兵真的会带走平民，会把他们的手捆起来，把他们都带出来，然后把他们全杀掉。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN].
[俄语交谈]。
I mean, that's just genocide to take people and tie their hands and shoot them. Well, I just psychologically refuse to believe in that.
我的意思是，带走人们把手捆起来杀掉，那简直是种族灭绝。嗯，我从心理上拒绝相信这一点。
So this was happening while they were driving through Spain, Nadia behind the wheel, reeling from the photos from Bucha that she had just seen; and Alex in the passenger seat, arguing his way out of believing that the atrocities actually happened. And the thing is, Nadia and her father are very close. They moved to Ukraine 20 years ago together because Alex wanted to try living there.
所以，当他们开车经过西班牙时，发生了这一切，娜迪亚在驾驶座上，因为刚看到的布查照片而感到痛苦；而亚历克斯在副驾驶座，用争辩的方式拒绝相信这些暴行确实发生过。问题是，娜迪亚和她父亲非常亲近。他们20年前一起搬到乌克兰，因为亚历克斯想尝试在那里生活。
They built that house together. They lived together. And she had just lived through the hell of not knowing if he was alive or dead. And now these pictures from Bucha, they showed how close the danger had been and just how awful. And this was the moment Alex chose to use the language of Russian propaganda and say maybe things were not so black and white?
他们一起盖了那座房子。他们住在一起。她刚刚经历了不知道他死活的地狱。而现在这些来自布查的照片显示了危险曾经有多近，情况有多可怕。这就是亚历克斯选择使用俄罗斯宣传语言、说事情也许没有那么非黑即白的时候？
And I remember, because we were driving through Spain, and it was heavy rain. And I said, "Please stop. Because if you weren't my father--"
我还记得，因为我们当时正开车经过西班牙，大雨滂沱。我说，“请停下。因为如果你不是我父亲——”
"If you weren't my father."
“如果你不是我父亲。”
"--I would get you out of the car here, even though it's rain." And I said, "Please stop, and let's never ever have this type of conversation again." And it was silent for a minute. And then he said, "Blood is not water."
“——我会把你赶下车，即使在下雨。”我说，“请停下，我们永远永远不要再进行这种谈话了。”沉默了一分钟。然后他说，“血浓于水。”
That's Russian for "blood is thicker than water."
那是俄语里的“血浓于水”。
He was trying to ease the situation. But that's when I understood that it's serious between us-- this gap.
他想缓和局面。但那时我意识到，我们之间很严重——这种鸿沟。
They kept driving in silence.
他们沉默着继续开车。
Masha Gessen. Coming up, after sending bombs and troops near to Nadia's house outside Kyiv, Russia sends her a bill. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
玛莎·格森。稍后，在向基辅外娜迪亚家附近发射炸弹并派遣军队后，俄罗斯给她寄来了一张账单。片刻之后回来，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "Eight Fights." If you're just tuning in, Masha Gessen is telling the story of one of the many families who have people on both sides of the border between Russia and Ukraine and the family fights they've gotten into since the Russian invasion. So far, Masha's friend Nadia has fought with her kid's dad, with her own father. Masha picks up where we left off.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是“八场争吵”。如果你刚加入，玛莎·格森正在讲述许多家庭的故事之一，这些家庭在俄罗斯和乌克兰边境两侧都有人，以及他们自俄罗斯入侵以来发生的家庭争吵。到目前为止，玛莎的朋友娜迪亚已经和她孩子的父亲、她自己的父亲吵过架了。玛莎将从我们中断的地方继续。
Fight number six-- about giving money to the Russian government. By spring of last year, a couple of months into the war, something changed in Nadia. Gone was the person who avoided fights. It was almost as if she wanted confrontation. And it so happened that at this time, notices from the Russian authorities started arriving at Nadia's mother's apartment in Moscow, indicating that Nadia needed to pay a fine.
第六场争吵——关于向俄罗斯政府交钱。到去年春天，战争进入两个月后，娜迪亚身上发生了变化。那个回避争吵的人不见了。她似乎渴望对抗。巧合的是，此时，俄罗斯当局的通知开始寄到娜迪亚母亲在莫斯科的公寓，显示娜迪亚需要缴纳罚款。
This was a fine she had already paid. She had a receipt. But the Russian state which was bombing Ukraine wanted more of Nadia's money.
这是一笔她已经缴纳过的罚款。她有收据。但那个正在轰炸乌克兰的俄罗斯国家想要更多娜迪亚的钱。
And then I've got a letter that I have to pay it again to the Ministry of Internal Affairs or something. And I was like, "Oh no, I'm not definitely paying no money to these guys in my life."
然后我收到一封信，说我必须再向内政部之类的部门缴纳。我说，“哦不，我这辈子绝不会再向这些人交一分钱。”
How much money are we talking about?
我们要说的是多少钱？
Oh god, some pathetic sum. Probably about 10,000 rubles. Which I don't know even how much money is that? I mean, it's not much.
天哪，一笔可怜的数目。大概10,000卢布吧。我甚至不知道那是多少钱？我的意思是，没多少。
It's under $100 I think.
我想不到100美元。
It's definitely under $100.
绝对不到100美元。
Nadia wanted her mother to do something about it. Nadia demanded that she go to the tax office and appeal the fine. She wanted her 70-year-old, five-foot-tall mother to go up against the Russian bureaucracy over less than $100. And she wouldn't let it go. She kept calling.
娜迪亚希望她母亲为此做点什么。娜迪亚要求她去税务局申诉罚款。她想让70岁、身高一米五的母亲去对抗俄罗斯官僚机构，就为了不到100美元。她就是不肯罢休。她不停地打电话。
Her mother understood why Nadia was upset. She opposes the war too. But she is Russian, and she looked at this fine the way a Muscovite does. She thought Nadia should forget about it.
她母亲理解娜迪亚为什么难过。她也反对这场战争。但她是俄罗斯人，她以莫斯科人的方式看待这笔罚款。她认为娜迪亚应该把它忘了。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN].
[俄语交谈]。
She's saying, "I mean, I live here. All my taxes, all my money, already goes to them anyway. So it's not a big deal for me." Nadia knows that her mother opposes the war. But that's just the thing that's driving her crazy, that her mother is so resigned.
她说，“我的意思是，我就住在这里。我所有的税，我所有的钱，反正都要交给他们。所以对我来说没什么大不了。”娜迪亚知道她母亲反对战争。但正是这一点让她发疯，她母亲竟如此顺从。
And I said that, you know, "That's the whole thing about you Russians, that you just can't be bothered. And you pay money to this government because you can't be bothered not to pay. And this is why the whole thing is happening."
我说，“这就是你们俄罗斯人的问题，你们就是太懒了。你们向这个政府交钱是因为你们懒得不去交。这就是这一切发生的原因。”
Fight number seven-- the Nice showdown. Five months into the war, Karen took Luka on vacation to Nice, to the beach. I can sort of imagine how Karen was feeling. He spent five months in shock and in a scramble-- emigrating, reorienting his professional life. And now here he was on vacation, in France.
第七场争吵——尼斯摊牌。战争进入五个月时，卡伦带卢卡去尼斯度假，去海滩。我多少能想象卡伦当时的感受。他在震惊和手忙脚乱中度过了五个月——移民、重新规划职业生活。现在他终于在法国度假了。
The buildings in Nice are white. The sea and the sky are blue. And even the ships, also white, look like they are there to complete the postcard view. Nice is a place a lot of people from the Russian Empire had gone to about 100 years earlier, fleeing the revolution and Civil War. Karen must have imagined that they experienced the same combination of feeling dislocated and soothed by the beauty of it all.
尼斯的建筑是白色的。大海和天空是蓝色的。即使是船只，也是白色的，看起来就像是为了完成明信片上的美景而存在。尼斯是很多俄罗斯帝国的人在大约100年前去过的地方，当时他们为了逃避革命和内战。卡伦一定想象过，他们经历了同样的流离失所，又被这一切的美丽所抚慰的感觉。
He took a picture of Luka at an outdoor restaurant table, his blond hair blowing against the blue, blue sky. And he sent it to Nadia with the caption-- "The latest wave of Russian immigrants in Nice." Russian immigrants. He wrote "Russian immigrants."
他在一家户外餐厅给卢卡拍了一张照片，卢卡金色的头发在蔚蓝的天空下飘动。他发给娜迪亚，配文——“尼斯最新的俄罗斯移民浪潮”。俄罗斯移民。他写的是“俄罗斯移民”。
You know, I was so angry. I took five minutes to smoke a cigarette. And then I was like, "Oh, calm down, calm down." I was like, "He's not Russian" I wrote him. And he replied, "Oh, neither are all of us."
你知道，我太生气了。我花了五分钟抽了支烟。然后我心想，“哦，冷静，冷静。”我写信告诉他，“他不是俄罗斯人。”他回答，“我们不也是吗。”
By this, Karen meant that ethnically he himself wasn't Russian. And anyway, as they'd already discussed, this whole topic of nationality was messy.
卡伦的意思是，从种族上讲，他自己并不是俄罗斯人。而且，正如他们已经讨论过的，民族这一整个话题本来就很混乱。
And then I had another cigarette, and I wrote, "No, no, no, you're Russian, and he's not." And he wrote, "Whatever."
我又抽了一支烟，我写道，“不，不，不，你是俄罗斯人，他不是。”他写道，“随便吧。”
And then I smoked another cigarette. And then I said, OK, no. I'm not going to leave it this time. And I wrote him everything. But this time, I was like, "No, no. Let's get it straight. We are Ukrainians." And I was like, "Now, please let us be Ukrainians because we want to be Ukrainians and we consider ourselves Ukrainians. And you are not. You're Russian."
我又抽了一支烟。我说，好吧，不。这次我不会就这么算了。我把一切都写给他了。但这次，我说，“不，不。咱们把话说清楚。我们是乌克兰人。”我说，“现在，请让我们成为乌克兰人，因为我们想成为乌克兰人，我们认为自己是乌克兰人。而你不是。你是俄罗斯人。”
Everything Nadia had kept bottled up for the last few months, for the last dozen years, came pouring out.
娜迪亚过去几个月、过去十几年里压抑的所有情绪，都倾泻而出。
And then I felt, now, I can't stop. Now, I cannot stop. I have to get it out of my system.
然后我感觉到，现在，我无法停止。现在，我无法停止。我必须把它发泄出来。
Do you have those texts?
你有那些短信吗？
I think, yes.
我想，有。
Can we look at them?
我们可以看看吗？
Now?
现在？
Yes.
是的。
She pulls up the photo from Nice and her first text.
她调出了那张来自尼斯的照片和她的第一条短信。
And then I go, "I really don't want to fight with you, but I really need to make it clear." And then I said, "Remember in Moscow, and you were really aggressive about Luka being in Ukrainian school and insisting that he must speak on the great Russian language, to read Tolstoy, and the greatest Russian culture, and all that? And Ukrainian, pathetic agricultural country, has no culture, and you can't stand that your son grows up in this pathetic place? And each time after holidays, Luka were coming with his brainwashed that he's not Ukrainian. And Ukrainian is all bullshit and not his.
然后我写，“我真的不想跟你吵，但我真的必须说清楚。”然后我说，“还记得在莫斯科，你对卢卡上乌克兰学校表现得非常有攻击性，坚持认为他必须讲伟大的俄语，读托尔斯泰，伟大的俄罗斯文化，等等？而乌克兰是可怜的农业国，没有文化，你无法忍受你的儿子在一个可怜的地方长大？每次假期后，卢卡回来都被洗脑认为他不是乌克兰人。乌克兰的一切都是狗屁，不是他的。”
She brings up the Crimea vacation, the globe--
她提到了克里米亚假期、地球仪——
The fucking globe [LAUGHING] for Crimea. And I was depressed because of this for several months. I even had to go to a psychologist to talk about it.
那个该死的地球仪[笑] 关于克里米亚。我为此抑郁了几个月。我甚至不得不去看心理医生谈论这件事。
I asked Karen to read his side of the conversation.
我请卡伦读了他那边的谈话。
She sent me a long message saying, "We are Ukrainians. We were always Ukrainians, and we will always be Ukrainians. In our home, Russians are killers, and it will be so until the war ends." And I was like, "OK, but I can recall our first-- when we first met with you in Kyiv." She made jokes of Ukrainian life or Kyiv as a city.
她发给我一条长信息说，“我们是乌克兰人。我们一直是乌克兰人，我们将永远是乌克兰人。在我们家，俄罗斯人是杀人犯，直到战争结束都会是这样。”我说，“OK，但我能回忆起我们第一次——当我们第一次在基辅见面时。”她拿乌克兰生活或基辅这座城市开玩笑。
She was making fun of some little details. And I was like, "OK. But remember, it's not just my own problem with this colonial mindset. You also had it when you just moved."
她拿一些细节开玩笑。我说，“OK。但记住，这不仅仅是我自己的殖民心态问题。你刚搬过去时也有这个问题。”
They had profoundly different recollections of some of the conversations they'd had early on in their relationship. Karen remembered Nadia making fun of some aspects of Ukrainian culture. Nadia remembered herself delighting in it. Now, Karen was the one who didn't want to fight. He texted back.
他们对恋爱初期的一些谈话有着截然不同的记忆。卡伦记得娜迪亚拿乌克兰文化的一些方面开玩笑。娜迪亚记得自己沉浸其中。现在，卡伦是那个不想吵架的人。他回信了。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN].
[俄语交谈]。
Each of us have our own path, our own traumas, and our own evolution. 12 years of my relationship with you is also 12 years of my relationship with Ukraine-- with all imperial ideas, internal xenophobia. So please, don't judge me so harshly.
我们每个人都有自己的道路，自己的创伤，自己的进化。我和你关系的12年，也是我与乌克兰关系的12年——伴随着所有的帝国思想、内在的仇外心理。所以请不要这么严厉地评判我。
But Nadia couldn't stop.
但娜迪亚无法停止。
"And I can't do anything with this horrible rage. And your son has to live with this mother which hates all Russian in the world and in herself. So at least please allow him not to be Russian and not to suffer from this. That's what we had." And then he's being really sweet. "I know what you feel." Blah, blah, blah.
“我无法消除这种可怕的愤怒。你的儿子必须和这个憎恨世界上一切俄罗斯事物、也憎恨自己身上俄罗斯印记的母亲生活在一起。所以至少请允许他不成为俄罗斯人，不承受这些。这就是我们所经历的。”然后他表现得真的很贴心。“我理解你的感受。”等等等等。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN].
[俄语交谈]。
To which I answer-- "Here, we have approached the most important part. Maybe you won't believe this, but every day I think about you and how painful this is.
我回答说——“在这里，我们触及了最重要的部分。也许你不相信，但我每天都在想你，以及这有多痛苦。
I understand how the war and pain cements your Ukrainian patriotism. And I respect that. Your personal history is your own business. I won't tell Luka anything. He'll come to understand everything himself one day."
我理解战争和痛苦是如何巩固你的乌克兰爱国主义的。我尊重这一点。你的个人历史是你自己的事。我不会告诉卢卡任何事情。他有一天会自己明白一切的。”
And that's it actually. And I said that we were done. I mean, I said everything I always wanted to. Yeah.
其实就是这样。我说我们要结束了。我的意思是，我说了所有我一直想说的话。是的。
What does it feel like reading this now?
现在读这些感觉如何？
I was-- actually, it's much better than I thought. I actually thought I was really aggressive. Because I really felt-- but it's really cool.
我当时——其实，比我想象的好多了。我真的以为我当时非常有攻击性。因为我真的感觉到——但这真的很酷。
Cool in what way? What are you seeing?
酷在哪里？你看到了什么？
I don't regret anything I said, not a word. I didn't lose it. Before, all these years, I've been too patient. And that's it. I think he got the point.
我不后悔我说过的任何话，一个字也不后悔。我没有失控。以前，这些年来，我太有耐心了。就是这样。我想他明白这一点了。
It's hard. I mean, I couldn't imagine that it would insult her, and I regret it. And it's hard to not just to [SPEAKING RUSSIAN].
这很难。我的意思是，我无法想象这会羞辱她，我感到后悔。如果不只是[俄语交谈]。
To admit your mistakes.
承认你的错误。
Admit. Yeah. It is not even hard to admit those mistakes. It is even harder to realize that you had those mistakes as your mindset for such a long time.
承认。是的。承认这些错误甚至不难。更难的是意识到这些错误作为你的思维方式持续了那么久。
Can you describe the mindset?
你能描述一下这种思维方式吗？
Uh. Mm-hmm.
呃。嗯。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]? I asked him if he wanted to switch to Russian.
[俄语交谈]？我问他是否想切换到俄语。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN].
[俄语交谈]。
It wouldn't be easier.
那不会更容易。
OK. Either way.
OK。都可以。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN].
[俄语交谈]。
This is difficult, you know? A lot of what Nadia remembers from this argument, for us, these were simply theoretical conversations about history. But as it turns out, the very things that me and others were talking about in this way, in this theoretical manner, they are now used as official reasons to justify the catastrophe, the atrocities.
这很困难，你知道吗？娜迪亚从这次争论中记得的很多事情，对我们来说，仅仅是关于历史的理论性谈话。但事实证明，我和其他人以这种方式、这种理论方式讨论的事情，现在正被用作证明这场灾难、这些暴行的官方理由。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN].
[俄语交谈]。
And these are words that you spoke, that came out of your mouth. And now, it makes you want to rinse it out with bleach and close it forever.
这些是你曾经说过的、从你嘴里说出来的话。现在，它让你想用漂白剂洗净它，永远把它关掉。
Now, Karen asked himself why he had taken these ideas for granted, even why he-- a Greek-Jewish-Armenian Russian-- had never questioned speaking the Russian language?
现在，卡伦问自己为什么要理所当然地接受这些想法，甚至为什么他——一个希腊-犹太-亚美尼亚血统的俄罗斯人——从未质疑过说俄语这件事？
And at that time, for the first time in my life-- I'm like 41 years old. And this is the first time when I ask myself, "what about me? Why I don't speak any of those languages and why I always answer that I'm Russian to anybody else and to myself."
而在那个时候，我人生中第一次——我已经41岁了。这是我第一次问自己，“我呢？为什么我不说任何那些语言，为什么我总是回答别人和自己，我是俄罗斯人。”
And also, why had he spent so much time and effort insisting that Nadia and Luka were Russian?
而且，为什么他花了那么多时间和精力坚持认为娜迪亚和卢卡是俄罗斯人？
Since now it is a burden for him, I'm like, oh, no. Forget it. Just leave it. You don't need it anymore. And let's pretend that you are not Russian at all. If it makes your life easier, you don't need to be.
既然这对他是种负担，我就说，噢，不。忘了它吧。直接放下它。你不再需要它了。让我们假装你根本不是俄罗斯人。如果这能让你的生活更轻松，你就没必要成为（俄罗斯人）。
Would you prefer not to be Russian too?
你也希望不是俄罗斯人吗？
No. Sorry. [LAUGHS] I wouldn't prefer that. I can't even imagine it because this is my country, and this is my culture. This is my problem also. This is my drama. Because I don't want to hide my identity. I don't want to try to escape from the responsibility I do have as a Russian person in this war.
不。抱歉。[笑] 我不希望那样。我甚至无法想象，因为这是我的国家，这是我的文化。这也是我的问题。这是我的戏剧。因为我不想隐藏我的身份。我不想试图逃避我作为一个俄罗斯人在这次战争中所承担的责任。
So let me sum this up a little bit. You were never accepted as Russian by Russians. You live in exile. The Russian government has declared you a foreign agent.
让我总结一下。你从未被俄罗斯人接纳为俄罗斯人。你流亡在外。俄罗斯政府宣布你是外国代理人。
Yes.
是的。
And you consider yourself Russian?
而你认为自己是俄罗斯人？
Does it sound like a sort of schizophrenia? [LAUGHS].
这听起来像是一种精神分裂吗？[笑]。
Karen is a journalist and an LGBTQ activist-- two things the Russian government hates most. That's why he's been designated a foreign agent. Nadia and Karen both felt better after that Nice fight. They'd cleared the air. Nadia felt heard.
卡伦是记者和LGBTQ活动家——俄罗斯政府最痛恨的两件事。这就是为什么他被指定为外国代理人。娜迪亚和卡伦在那次尼斯争吵后都感觉好多了。他们扫清了阴霾。娜迪亚感到被听见了。
Karen felt like he'd understood something. For one thing, he understood why Nadia said that she and Luka were Ukrainian and how important that was. Their relationship improved. And also, a new Nadia had emerged-- one who told people what she really thought-- except when she didn't.
卡伦觉得他懂了一些东西。一方面，他理解了娜迪亚为什么说她和卢卡是乌克兰人，以及这有多重要。他们的关系改善了。此外，一个新的娜迪亚出现了——一个会告诉人们她真实想法的人——除了她不说的时候。
Number eight-- the fight that wasn't. Nadia comes from a long line of diplomats. Her grandparents were diplomats, and her mother really hoped Nadia would be a diplomat too, which brings me to Nadia's stepfather-- the man who was present for most of Nadia's childhood.
第八场争吵——没发生的争吵。娜迪亚出身于外交官世家。她的祖父母是外交官，她的母亲真的希望娜迪亚也成为外交官，这让我谈到了娜迪亚的继父——那个在娜迪亚大部分童年时期都在身边的人。
Nadia adored him. She calls him Dad. She never called Alex that. Long after he and Nadia's mother divorced, they stayed in touch. As Nadia became an adult, they spoke less often. But every time he called, it was like they'd seen each other just yesterday.
娜迪亚崇拜他。她叫他爸爸。她从没那样叫过亚历克斯。在他和娜迪亚的母亲离婚很久之后，他们一直保持联系。随着娜迪亚成年，他们通话少了。但每次他打电话来，都像昨天刚见过面一样。
And he was also a diplomat. In fact, he still is a diplomat, a Russian diplomat who is still working in a high post. And after the war started, and they fled to Lisbon, and she got Alex out of Ukraine, Nadia was starting to dread her dad's phone call-- the call she'd always looked forward to.
而且他也是外交官。事实上，他现在还是外交官，一位目前担任高职的俄罗斯外交官。战争开始后，他们逃到里斯本，她把亚历克斯从乌克兰救出来，娜迪亚开始害怕她爸爸的电话——那个她一直期待的电话。
Her birthday's at the end of May, and he always called. This time, she'd have to assume that their conversation was monitored. So if she told him what had been happening for her since the war began. Even if all he did was listen, that could get him in trouble.
她的生日在五月底，他总是会打电话。这一次，她不得不假设他们的谈话被监听了。所以如果她告诉他自战争开始以来对她来说发生了什么。即使他只是听着，那也可能让他惹上麻烦。
But what if he didn't just listen? What if he said the sort of thing a man in his position is expected to say-- defending the invasion, justifying it. She was scared he'd say something unforgivable. She was scared she'd say something that would get him in trouble. She was also maybe scared she'd say nothing and regret it.
但如果他不仅仅是听着呢？如果他说了那个职位的人被期望说的话——为入侵辩护，证明其合理性。她害怕他会说出不可原谅的话。她害怕自己会说出让他惹上麻烦的话。她也可能害怕自己什么都不说，然后后悔。
He's quite old, so he'll be retired soon. So he's got, like, a few years left. And he achieved what he was always wanted since he was a child. And I mean, it's everything he's got-- it's really-- I know it's important for him. And it's his job, and he can't do anything else.
他年纪很大了，所以很快就会退休。所以他剩下的时间不多了。他实现了他从小就一直想要的东西。我的意思是，这是他拥有的一切——真的很——我知道这对他很重要。这是他的工作，他做不了别的。
He has the option of retiring now.
他现在有退休的选择。
I don't know. I really-- I don't doubt that he's a fantastic person. And whatever happens to him, I just hope he's going to be all right. I just really don't want to hurt him, and I feel really sorry for him. And I think he is in a really complicated position. And I think he's really sorry and he's suffering in a way.
我不知道。我真的——我不怀疑他是个出色的人。无论他发生什么，我只希望他一切都好。我真的不想伤害他，我真的为他感到难过。我认为他处于一个非常复杂的境地。我认为他真的感到抱歉，他正在某种程度上遭受折磨。
He didn't call.
他没打电话。
I thought this would be a story about how war makes everything black and white. It does. I've seen it. And everyone you heard from in this episode has seen it. Long-suppressed disagreements become fights to the death. Fuzzy lines turn into firm boundaries. Nothing is left unsaid. It's true.
我以为这是一个关于战争如何让一切非黑即心的故事。确实如此。我见识过。你们在本集中听到的每个人也都见识过。长期压抑的分歧变成了生死之争。模糊的界限变成了坚定的分界线。没有什么话是不说的。确实如此。
Most Ukrainians I have interviewed in a year and a half of covering the war have heartbreaking stories about their relationships with family in Russia. But who was I kidding? When are family conflicts ever resolved decisively? When are family stories ever black and white?
我在一年半的战争报道中采访过的大多数乌克兰人，都有关于他们与俄罗斯亲人关系的令人心碎的故事。但我是在自欺欺人吗？家庭冲突何时能彻底解决？家庭故事何时是非黑即白的？
Nadia, for instance, could have a weeks-long fight with her mom about giving less than $100 to the Russian government. She contemplated throwing her father out of the car for being unable to face the war crimes in Bucha. She flew into a rage in response to the way Karen captioned a photo of Luka. But she wasn't going to say a word to her stepdad who is actually serving the Russian state?
例如，娜迪亚可以为了向俄罗斯政府缴纳不到100美元的罚款，跟她母亲吵上好几个星期。她曾考虑过把她父亲赶下车，因为他无法正视布查的战争罪行。她对卡伦给卢卡照片配文的方式感到狂怒。但她却不打算对她那实际上正在为俄罗斯国家服务的继父说一个字？
An epilogue-- the Russian-Ukrainian war has been going on for more than 500 days. Nadia, Sophie, and Luka are still living in Lisbon. Karen is in Berlin. A few weeks ago, the Russian government added him to its list of extremists and terrorists. This means that he will be arrested if he ever tries to go back to Russia.
尾声——俄乌战争已经持续了500多天。娜迪亚、苏菲和卢卡仍然住在里斯本。卡伦在柏林。几周前，俄罗斯政府将他列入了极端分子和恐怖分子名单。这意味着如果他试图回到俄罗斯，他就会被逮捕。
When the announcement came out, Nadia called him and said, "You're one of us now." Alex and Lena, Nadia's father and Sophie's mother returned to Ukraine after Russian troops were pushed back from Kyiv. They've fixed up the house and taken the blankets off the windows. They're still very much in love. The cats weathered their absence fine.
公告出来时，娜迪亚打电话给他，说：“你现在是其中一员了。”亚历克斯和莉娜，娜迪亚的父亲和苏菲的母亲，在俄军被从基辅击退后回到了乌克兰。他们修好了房子，撤下了窗户上的毯子。他们依然深深相爱。猫儿们也平安度过了它们的缺席时光。
The rest of this epilogue is going to be about Luka because most of these fights were about him. Luka turned 12 earlier this year. He wanted to get a Harry Potter cake to bring to school. Then Nadia suggested they get a blue and yellow one instead-- the colors of the Ukrainian flag. And he agreed.
这段尾声的其余部分将是关于卢卡的，因为这些争吵大部分都是关于他的。卢卡今年早些时候12岁了。他想买一个哈利·波特蛋糕带到学校。然后娜迪亚建议他们换成蓝黄色的——乌克兰国旗的颜色。他同意了。
When Luka heard that I was interviewing his parents, he volunteered to talk to me. But when I asked him about specific conflicts from the past, the vyshyvanka fight, the Crimean vacation fight, the globe fight, he drew a blank.
当卢卡听说我正在采访他的父母时，他主动提出跟我谈谈。但当我问他过去发生具体冲突时，刺绣衫之争，克里米亚度假之争，地球仪之争，他却一片空白。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN].
[俄语交谈]。
I mean, I remember. It was on one of my birthdays that I was given a globe. But it was kind of broke--
我的意思是，我记得。是在我某次生日时有人送了我一个地球仪。但它有点坏了——
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN].
[俄语交谈]。
I don't know. I don't remember any globe.
我不知道。我不记得什么地球仪。
The Ukrainian flag cake was Nadia's idea, but Luka has been standing up for the Ukrainian flag in his own way. He plays video games online with other Russian-speaking kids.
乌克兰国旗蛋糕是娜迪亚的主意，但卢卡一直以自己的方式捍卫乌克兰国旗。他在网上与其他讲俄语的孩子玩电子游戏。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN].
[俄语交谈]。
There is a game there where you have to draw. And there are people on there. Some of them draw the Russian flag, and somebody draws the Ukrainian flag. And then at some point, in the chat room, they argue why Ukraine is better, why Russia will win, and so on and so forth.
那里有一个游戏，你必须画画。上面有人。有些人画俄罗斯国旗，有些人画乌克兰国旗。然后在某个时候，在聊天室里，他们争论为什么乌克兰更好，为什么俄罗斯会赢，等等等等。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]? I asked him, "Do you participate in these arguments?"
[俄语交谈]？我问他，“你参加这些争论吗？”
No. [SPEAKING RUSSIAN].
不。[俄语交谈]。
If I get a chance, I'm 100%. I'm fighting for Ukraine for real. And now, I consider myself 100% Ukrainian. I wouldn't feel comfortable living in the same country as Putin.
如果我有机会，我会100%参与。我是在真正地为乌克兰而战。现在，我100%认为自己是乌克兰人。我不会觉得和普京生活在同一个国家很舒服。
A year and a half ago, so many things about Luka and his life were contested. Where was he going to go if a war began and for how long? Who was he-- Russian, Ukrainian, both, German? Now, he's Ukrainian-- but a Ukrainian who plans to live in Germany when he grows up. If he has children, he will raise them speaking Ukrainian. He told me, though, that he may need to hire a tutor.
一年半前，关于卢卡和他生活的很多事情都有争议。战争开始时他去哪里，去多久？他是谁——俄罗斯人、乌克兰人、两者兼有、还是德国人？现在，他是乌克兰人——但一个计划长大后住在德国的乌克兰人。如果他有了孩子，他会用乌克兰语抚养他们。不过他告诉我，他可能需要请个家教。
Masha Gessen is a staff writer for The New Yorker and the author of several books, including the Future is History.
玛莎·格森是《纽约客》的特约撰稿人，也是多本书的作者，包括《未来即历史》。
Masha's story in today's program was produced by Valerie Kipnis and some Russian journalists-- Andrey Borzenko and Lika Kremer. They're co-founders of the podcast company Libo/Libo which makes podcasts in Russian. This story is a co-production with them, our first. Their website libolibo.me.
玛莎在今天节目中的故事由瓦莱丽·基普尼斯和一些俄罗斯记者——安德烈·博尔任科和利卡·克雷默制作。他们是播客公司Libo/Libo的联合创始人，该公司制作俄语播客。这个故事是与他们的联合制作，我们的第一次。他们的网站 libolibo.me。
The people who put together today's program include Bim Adewunmi, James Bennett II, Zoe Chace, Michael Comite, Aviva DeKornfeld, Cassie Howley, Seth Lind, Stowe Nelson, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Ike Sriskandarajah, Marisa Robertson-Texter, Matt Tierney, Nancy Updike, Diane Wu. Our Managing Editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our Senior Editor is David Kestenbaum. Our Executive Editor is Emanuel Berry.
制作今天节目的人员包括Bim Adewunmi、James Bennett II、Zoe Chace、Michael Comite、Aviva DeKornfeld、Cassie Howley、Seth Lind、Stowe Nelson、Ryan Rumery、Alissa Shipp、Ike Sriskandarajah、Marisa Robertson-Texter、Matt Tierney、Nancy Updike、Diane Wu。我们的执行编辑是Sarah Abdurrahman。我们的高级编辑是David Kestenbaum。我们的执行编辑是Emanuel Berry。
Special thanks today to Misha Galkin and Mark Kipnis, who you heard doing English voiceovers. Pyotr Ruzavin, Sofi Pashkual and her mom, Yelena Vernigora, Yana Mandrikina, and Stephen Steinberg. Our website, thisamericanlife.org. You can stream our archive of over 800 episodes for absolutely free. Also, we have on there now new merch, including genuinely wonderful Torey Mala-T-shirts. Take a look-- you'll see what I'm talking about.
今天特别感谢Misha Galkin和Mark Kipnis，你们听到了他们做的英文配音。Pyotr Ruzavin，Sofi Pashkual和她的母亲Yelena Vernigora，Yana Mandrikina，以及Stephen Steinberg。我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。你可以免费流媒体播放我们超过800集的档案。此外，我们上面现在有新的周边商品，包括真正棒极了的Torey MalaT恤。看一眼——你会明白我在说什么。
Again, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Special thanks as always to our program's confounder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He told me recently, "That's it. No more pasta. No more rewatching The Godfather. No more gabagool."
再次重申，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交换中心PRX发送给公共广播电台。一如既往，特别感谢我们节目的联合创始人Torey Malatia先生。他最近告诉我，“够了。不要再吃意大利面了。不要再重看《教父》了。不要再吃碎肉香肠了。”
No, no, no. I'm German. I'm definitely German.
不，不，不。我是德国人。我绝对是德国人。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。